the balls is such a difficult position
for Judah to play and he needs more of
that we need to see more of that
creative genius Spark and now he has the
white pieces here we go David yeah here
we go we're off in game two of today and
uh my major off starting with the
Queen's Pawn what is he gonna try he
needs to keep the momentum I think the
last thing mamajaro should do is play it
safe in this game just keep going for
Duda while he's a bit off balance
especially before he recovers Duda from
that last defeat that would have been a
crushing feeling just uh losing when
you're a queen up for just a rook but uh
yeah my major just like you said Ivanka
at some point everyone blunders in chess
it's just about how you spin it after
that how you recover how you react and
manager set his opponent some practical
problems he's got to do the same in this
red goes in defense uh it's a branch of
the Queen's camper declined this bishop
coming out means it's there it goes in
one of the favorites of Levon aronian
Magnus Carlson has played this plenty of
times all the top guys have this in
their repertoire white Bishop coming out
to pin the Black Knight yep and uh thank
them you have some choices here you can
either capture the pawn or you can
attack the bishop
and uh other of course there are other
moves in the position
plenty of options here for black and uh
what we'll do to choose
I'm guessing he's going to attack this
bishop with the black pawn yeah I think
I've seen two to play that before
but
yeah it's uh it's still a very
theoretical position
still it's just choosing your poison as
they say okay he does take the pawn and
uh he used to do this all the time so
it's transposing to what we call the
Vienna uh the Vienna Gambit so White's
actually down upon black has essentially
seized the Queen's Gambit he said yep
you go up to the point I'm gonna take it
I'm going to defend it but what Black's
doing now with his pawns on this left
side it's a bit
it's a bit convoluted in a way it feels
very shaky black is taking risks and if
things do collapse if black loses his
extra opponent then white just has a
nice Pawn Center yeah
well well white has various ways to
handle this position and the most
popular move by far is the one that
mamajarov has played and do that
immediately challenging in the center so
so far or standard stuff all been played
before but I think both sides will be
happy because the position now will be
quite Sharp yeah that's very English
review Ivanka quite sharp I know yes
it's going to be exclusive
fire on the board it's such a bad habit
of mine to kind of do this British thing
or just a little bit so just a little
bit drama
I know
gotta tone it down because people you
know unless you're British and you know
that I'm kind of like tongue-in-cheek
then uh yeah
can't be misunderstood no don't stop
doing it I I would actually say British
people must be the most Charming people
you think that's a common British people
very Charming with the politeness
which is acting
horrible people deep down no no no no no
that's the stereotype that we're like
Hugh Grant like oops yeah exactly
and I remember when my my parents moved
over to England
um the thing that made my mom laughed is
this a clock 11 o'clock yeah that's true
yes Brits but meanwhile this position is
slightly sharp it's uh it is exploding
in the center if you look at the pawn
structure already it's just a mess uh
black has two in the center one of
them's about to be captured
um I'm not 100 familiar with the theory
in this position I vaguely remember
looking at it a while ago and then just
deciding I'm not going to try this as
black because I couldn't figure out what
was going on but uh let's jump in right
now it is black I think with an extra
Pawn but this guy is gonna be captured
I'm assuming
um you can capture it first of all with
a knight if you want to or you can maybe
if I remember correctly take this Knight
off the board first those are the two
options is much more popular to capture
the porn with the Knight though yeah so
the idea is this Knight is pinned you
can't move it uh it's pinned on this
diagonal so you have to remove one of
the attackers of that piece so the most
popular move is Knight takes pawn and uh
White's Bishop is actually going to
Spring out and capture this guy on the
next couple of turns so white will
likely go Pawn up but black is very
active black is actually the first one
the castle often in these positions
black has a nice pin on this diagonal
the reason a guest manageriff is pausing
now is he's just trying to it's a matter
of taste in this position uh he's just
trying to choose what to play I do
remember that this was a move Bishop
takes Knight as you mentioned you make
it's the maybe the second main move and
after the black queen recaptures now the
difference is the White Queen can take
this pawn and uh the game would maybe be
a bit calmer if the Queens do disappear
if the Queen's uh are traded enough you
can't do that in the current position
just to clarify you can't trade off the
Queens yet because after a queen
exchange the fact that this Knight still
lives on the board means that Knight
takes porn as possible again profiting
from this pin and now black is actually
winning because there's an attack
against this Knight there's an attack
against this bishop and black is also a
pawn up
so those are the two options
chaos as we said and it's likely to stay
that way for some time even after those
moves we suggested but we're expecting
okay one of those two moves Shaq does
indeed capture the Knight this hints to
me that he wants to play it slightly
safer because as we showed the Queens
are likely to get traded
and after Queen takes Bishop I'm
expecting Shaq now the differences that
you can take with the queen
and yeah heading towards an end game
still a crazy end game still very
imbalanced
so not a draw for not anything too calm
or too boring but could he try to uh let
Duda keep his Queen yeah seems he always
wins the game and he's the only one
missing the queen
give up the White Queen you don't need
it
that's true actually normally I
associate Shaq's attacks with uh you
know Queens coming to Checkmate the
black the enemy King and he did
Checkmate there in the last game but
without a queen it's just incredible
yeah it's almost once in a lifetime for
most players but for Shaq it's like
three times a tournament yeah
sacrificing a queen uh he literally
sacked his Queen to win against Gary
against Rapport and now against Duda
incredible yeah wow I know it seems to
be something that he should do more
often and whilstuda is considering which
way to capture that Bishop I'm it's much
more common for the queen to go and
capture the bishop as David has
indicated well I'll share with you
another meme this time it comes from
murali De Haram who says this one is
very standard they've been there I've
been there
you sleep brain goes but what have you
had moved the night and you're like shut
up I'm trying to sleep and then
let me check on my phone it happens to
me all the time it does it
it's like it doesn't let go you think
that you've gone especially happens
after a loss and yeah
it's the stuff of nightmares because it
won't go away and there we actually see
Duda he wants to gamble he wants to take
risks oh he's actually capture the piece
with his pawn it has been played before
I have to say but not the most popular
response yeah I guess simply because
black has a set of double pawns now on
the file and if Black's King were ever
to Castle on that side of the board it
would be vulnerable so due to taking
risks he does have slightly more central
control because that pawn covers some
key Central squares but uh yeah not the
usual method William Castle now in this
game if the Queens come off the board
Black's King will be safe whether it
castles whether it stays in the center
but now now my Majora's like okay you've
ruined your Pawn structure time to keep
the Queens on half so now if the black
king does Castle over to this right side
then the White Queen can go and attack
it so uh Mama giraffe that's how the top
players they're so good they're very
flexible it's like Mama jar of he was
ready to trade off the Queens he wanted
to but Duda does something a bit weird
and he's like actually no no no I'm
Gonna Keep the Queens on because I think
black's King is going to be more
vulnerable than whites yeah that must be
some of the hardest things in chess when
you have this great plan yeah just to
change it yeah it's uh it's not
following dogmatic thinking all the time
it's uh yeah it's being flexible it's
actually thinking on the Fly and that's
why the top players they calculate so
much because sometimes you calculate
your plan doesn't actually work so you
have to go and uh kind of switch the
move order or be a bit creative and
temporarily wait to pawn up his Bishop's
just gone to capture a pawn
and do that what's he gonna do with the
black king
black can regain a pawn actually black
light squared Bishop can go and capture
White's Pawn in the middle of the board
that pawn is not defended because
White's Knight is pinned by the other
Bishop
but it loses a lot of time white is
ready to Castle perhaps
really sharp I have a feeling that this
is going to be decisive as well this
game yeah absolutely and I do feel that
Black's position is very precarious and
he steps forward with the queen to
attack the bishop
um hit the white the black king is just
not safe and oh my God look at the bar
what is happening I mean why is it going
up so much I mean is it I think it's
just because of blacks for precarious uh
King situation yeah I think you just I
don't think you should Retreat that
Bishop for instance defend it
yep I agree 100 your bank and there's
some easy natural moves to defend it
um it's attacked this piece it's loose
if you step it back the problem is now
black can uh gang and cash it uh cash in
on this night uh he's ganging up on this
piece so after a couple of Trades this
check is really awkward to deal with you
don't want to investigate that variation
so White's Queen I guess can you just
come and defend it the most natural move
to me absolutely defending the piece but
also asking an awkward question of the
black bishop and Black's Bishop for
example it can trade off for the White
Knight fine uh White can take this back
in two different ways but yes black can
again uh gained the pawn back so now it
would be level material but already
white is lining up some sacrifices on
the Square I'd be really tempted here
for white to start calculating for
example Bishop takes porn and uh the
White Queen jumping in
it gets super sharp here I'm not 100
sure of the evaluation but this is the
type of thing that's going on in their
mind
and uh
Shaq if this works for him which the
computer seems to think it does then
he's got a great position yeah you can
also play it safe you don't have to use
the square you can for example move your
queen to the square also Defending Your
Bishop
yeah I don't play it safe
it's a sharp position it's open play the
most active move if you can so uh this
one I like because it also gains time as
David indicated attacking the bishop and
setting up all those potential
sacrifices that white will always have
um I really think that
Duda and it's only moved how what type
of move is it it's 12 is it already in
survival mode yeah it feels like he's on
tilt dude a body language is negative
he's been shaking his head a bit this
game he's freestyling in an opening you
need to know all the details
um as I mentioned I looked at this
opening a few months ago for black and I
decided you know there's too many
minefields
um too much room for error from a human
point of view none of them moves are
natural you can't just freestyle
especially in a rapid game maybe in a
long game you can calculate your way out
of trouble but look at the evaluation
bar shooting up and are we still in the
opening yeah yeah neither King has
castled
and uh it's only move 13 and wow this is
like a red red rack to the bull he's
just asking Mama giraffe to sacrifice
um so he's attacking with this Last
Retreat he's attacking White's Knight in
the center of the board
but first of all that Knight can be
defended with White's rook in the corner
White's Rook on the left can just slide
over behind this Knight in the middle
and defend it
secondly you could jump forward and give
up this white knight for a couple of
Pawns
slightly tempting
highly tempting actually and what do you
think Ivanka is not majority is going to
play
safe with this Knight is there anything
immediately that you see no I don't see
anything immediate but uh you know what
I'm thinking I'm thinking that he might
defend it with his work but via the mean
of course of castling or something but
maybe that's just too much yeah I mean
it's it's on the radar right so this
Knight is attacked the reason I'm
slightly tempted to calculate this move
Knight takes porn is because once the
bishop recaptures you have three pawns
for a piece so it's actually level
material but also this bishop covers any
square that the black king will ever
Castle to so Black's King is trapped in
the center for the rest of the game
that being said no direct threats for
white so it's understandable to want to
avoid this and this one would need a lot
of good judgment and like you said the
safer move
is which one is
of course it's Shack it's sacrium
sacrificing
the safe one I was about to say is to
bring the Rook across but nope no safety
here and this King now is going to be a
target for the rest of the game stuck
stranded in the center wow white king it
looks like it's stuck in the center as
well but it still can Castle on both
sides of the wood watch out for Shaq
Castle in Queen side maybe with
devastating effect later on when
doodally suspects it computer doesn't
approve but it's one of those positions
it could swing in either side's favor if
anyone makes a mistake now high stakes
chess
this is the chest we were hoping for
yeah yesterday we were so close so many
times but dude it was always able to
shut down my major yeah not today but uh
Duda had his own brand of very Dynamic
chess actually that completely baffled
I'm a giraffe and here we see almost at
these the two last games that they
played had been in mamajarov's territory
the position has been very open
um the Kings have been unsafe and this
is where Mama jar of just cells I mean
he's so good at calculation he's so good
with activity and as David mentioned you
know he's great at attacking with pieces
so Judas King is in hot water right now
and uh whilst he's thinking about how to
repair okay he develops his Knight this
is very natural
I I want to share with you one meme from
a giraffe Mukherjee okay we see White
Castle the king get its safety the black
king is still so unsafe the Rooks are
going to come in and uh it's very
relatable he says and I'm gonna
hopefully I'll come up and it says here
I love this one my coach impressed I
didn't take a seemingly hanging Pawn
because it drops a piece after a five
move sequence
me not seeing the hanging porn
and is this from the office is Steve
Carell Carell yeah
yeah I like that with especially with
the Bomb Bag as well and the hairstyle I
was talking to all of us at some point
as well
plundering our way through life
yep yeah
uh yeah excellent means you guys keep
them coming and remember use the hashtag
chess champs for a chance to win a mug
of David Howell
my face I don't know why anyone would
want that but you have the opportunity
it's a very nice mug it is look at that
it's very cool it's very cool I've drunk
out of that exact cup
anyway uh moving on
um yeah I'm just wondering now Duda in
thought for over a minute what do you
think Ivanka is he gonna get Brave do
that and Castle queenside I'm saying
this really reluctantly because it looks
so ugly but I don't see what else to do
um dude is King you need to sort it out
before the white Rooks centralize and
start going for that black king before
White's Knight stops jumping forward
it makes sense doesn't it I mean the
other option is
[Laughter]
the other option is to live with the
king in the center and we can't go for
that it feels no man's number yeah if
you keep your king in the middle exactly
so I agree with you I mean My Vibe was
just a castle
to the left because uh yeah I was just
trying to scout out the position to see
where the king wants to be ideally and
if it does Castle Queen side it's not
safe here obviously because of this
diagonal and it's also on an open file
however this King which looks really
really weak on this side of the wood if
you just give it one more move for
example if white just takes the time out
very natural Rook move the king will
slide across as Suddenly It's much safer
right suddenly actually this white Pawn
is blocking the attacks towards it it's
defended by its Bishop
relatively safe I'm still scared as
black to have my king on this side of
the board it looks far more open than
White's King which is nicely protected
by pawns but
to me it looks like he has to try this
at some point if you don't go for this
how are you ever getting your rook in
the game really if at first I thought oh
maybe the back Knight will jump but
again white for example has options such
as
leaping forward with the white knight
this looks very strong uh White to Rook
can also slide across there's going to
be tactics
left right and Center yeah actually left
right and Center in this position
literally on this side of the board on
right side of the board and in the
center with the King and he hasn't
castled
okay he brought his Rook into the game
but
he's leaving a Sitting Duck in the
center of the board
clear Target
oh what do you think of this one I I
don't like it I mean I I agree with you
I was also afraid of the night jumping
in and opening lines I was
terrified of the white the black king
being in the middle yeah the black king
is destined to be in the middle now for
the rest of the game it will never
Castle on the other side of the board
because white covers that square too
many times
and uh yeah I mean this moves definitely
on the radar jumping forward if you want
to kind of wait and kind of save them
what not uh keep it up your sleeve for
later then maybe this move uh again I
just see some tactics along this file
um it's actually hard for the black
queen to find a safe Square maybe she
has to go to the center of the ward now
maybe that's the only safe Square for
the black queen again Rook opposite
Queen ends in disaster as we nearly saw
in the last game
yeah um so many touching options
definitely and I was kind of
you might approve but you might also
frown and say to me hey HS is timing
you're not being energetic enough but I
was also thinking of the king sliding
over to the H1 square and play it and
then a positional way I approve you
Banker I will never ever criticize a
nice kind of safe strategic move even if
the time is wrong I like the idea
no I mean this one makes sense as well
because uh it's not just getting the
king off this diagonal right yeah or off
this open file
um it's also you might want to push your
pawns forward I do want to push the pawn
forward not necessarily to explode open
the position but actually to control the
squares and especially the E5 Square in
the middle because actually this might
be the only safe Square for the Black
Knight but also for the black queen for
example in that variation we showed the
black queen wanted to Loop into the
center now there's no more pin on this
diagonal you push forward kick her away
okay okay he does jump in as we
mentioned this is very tempting as well
um so attacking the black queen now I
don't think you can tolerate this Knight
in the center of the board much longer
evaluation bus still says it's good for
white maybe not the best move but very
human and we've learned that Shaq has
his own uh evaluation style in his head
queens and Rooks are basically worth the
same so yeah
Quinn now attacked so I think I would
just capture this Knight without
hesitation
I would probably just lift and regret it
immediately but I would take this piece
off the board
what is Shaq's idea here
looks tempting to take with the queen
there's a threat now of coming across
and checking the black king but maybe
the Black Knight could have moved out
the way and blocked that idea okay he
take he doesn't go for this and Ivanka
you're excited I'm very excited because
the move I suggested has been played you
know the night came in I agree with you
you should have taken that night off as
too dangerous can't let her live and uh
you know she the queen came to the E5
square and the King moved over to H1
small moves and the big consequences
because of course F2 F4 is coming yeah
this move was no longer not earlier
possible now it's a big big threat and
we should mention this bishop it is on
priest it is loose but don't take it
it's poisoned if you take the bishop
then you walk into a night Fork
you would lose your queen so still I
mean it's really tense in the middle of
the board it's really packed in the
center there with all these four pieces
but again it's about the black king and
uh slowly pieces are gravitating towards
it
yeah I mean this looks absolutely
terrifying for black uh this Pawn push
is gonna just
I mean it's gonna blast everything out
of the way and White's Rook could open
up on this f file as well the other Rook
can swing across any time
black is essentially playing without
this piece as well it's stuck in the
corner if you can't Castle
you're essentially playing a rook down
you have an extra Bishop for three white
pawns so level material but you're
playing a rook down in the corner
dude uh he doesn't look happy at all
yeah he makes his King with good reason
and uh at least now black is uh
threatening to capture the bishop and
Mama jarov instantly you know applies
the pressure and look at that the queen
moves over to the right and is actually
threatening to lift herself up all the
way to the H6 Square to deliver what is
virtually Checkmate and the bar is now
saying Chuck is winning yep and you can
see it on duda's face he was shaking his
head
shock is just so inspired today he woke
up on the right side of bed we've got to
say and what a move he plays it
instantly as you mentioned Ivanka this
bishop is now attacked because no more
checks but uh the just the general full
board awareness to swing your queen the
whole way across instantly uh to switch
angles defending the bishop also helping
an attack against this whoops Iris he's
helping an attack against this Knight
and uh the more deadly threat of all of
them is as you mentioned Ivanka this
check
how'd you defend maybe you just don't
maybe it's it is time to resign
ing isn't it it's I mean it's such a
horrible position yeah and the black
king unsafe none of Black's pieces can
assist this poor creature
and it's so rare I think that we see a
player make a move and the bar just
grows after they're move usually it just
goes down and it goes up for the other
players move
is this a genius move that Mom Daryl has
made moving his Queen yeah I think it's
not just one genius move as well it's a
genius concept so it's um Shakura as we
saw in the last game he sacrificed his
Queen for a rook and from a human point
of view it looks like okay
material down you're losing but he sees
long term there's actually compensation
there's practical problems for your
opponent for the next 10 moves and this
queen move was set up by his last few
but it's not obvious for humans first of
all because it's part of a bigger plan
but it's also not obvious for humans uh
sorry not obviously computers because uh
uh normally computers they want to look
at the forcing moves first but he's just
slowly setting up the threats he's
slowly building up all the pieces
and uh plus five now it's growing even
more Kyle like you say and that's
because the computer is now realizing
there's just no defense
Duda realized very quickly there was no
way back
he was shaking his head he realized he's
about to get checkmated or he's about to
lose that Black Knight
then he'll just be three-point star for
nothing wow but uh computers maybe they
were trying to find ways to defend
they're not working
so Shaq has that instinct but he also
has the imagination to come up with
these uh crazy plans yeah yeah
well to even suggest a surviving move
for Duda and uh I was looking at him in
the camera he knows it so I think this
is just a random move just to perhaps
I put uh kind of distract Mama jar off
but nope nothing's gonna happen here
he's uh in full control
yeah I mean you could just take this
Pawn with the white Bishop for example I
agree yeah there's one defensive idea
that if the White Queen slides up with
that check that we mentioned now uh that
we mentioned on the last turn that
Black's Queen actually can jump back to
defend her King so Retreat squares have
been created for the black queen
I think dude I had to try this there was
just nothing else but uh yeah just take
that pawn and actually White's attacking
material up white will have four pawns
for Black's Bishop
uh yeah Duda he he's been hit by uh just
a storm today in the two games both
games
how is Judah gonna recover from this
shaking his head
do you think already we're only in move
19. we're going to see him resign quite
soon
no I don't think he's going to resign
just yet I mean because it's a badge
it's I don't know it's not badge of
honor but you do not want to lose an
under 20 moves then you'll fall that
falls under the category of miniature
and you might find yourself in the wrong
end of a miniature book and you're just
like no that doesn't happen and so you'd
like to kind of drag the game on you
know say 25 moves that's okay won't get
in there and but this is just a
masterpiece from chakria
as so instrumental how he uses all his
pieces and as David says we're just
expecting Bishop takes porn simple as
best
yeah you're right Ivanka you'll end up
in every newspaper every chess column
around the world if uh if you're losing
less than 20 moves because computers
sorry newspapers they have a certain
amount of space and they need quick
short games pretty games pretty attacks
you're going to put it on your column
I'll put it in my newspaper for this
game if uh
meanwhile again he surprises us he
surprises Duda not maybe with the most
obvious move but I think equally strong
it is very strong look at the White
Queen she's attacking that black rook in
the middle of the board and it's
undefended how do you hold on to it
the black Rook is tied down defending
its Knights
can't defend that piece no you can't it
definitely you can't and
that's such a classy move once again you
know chakra are not playing the most
obvious instead he's all about applying
pressure on Duda and The Duda shaking
his head he knows he's in big big
trouble yeah
okay he just gives up the black Rook at
least he gets rid of one attacking piece
for white uh The Rook does drop
Black's King is gonna move again no safe
squares though you can block with the
black queen Maybe
but everything's falling it's like your
your opponent's in your house just
grabbing everything now they're grabbing
all your possessions grabbing all your
pieces
falling down and still the black king is
so unsafe I mean if if the king had some
shelter it could hide behind Black's
position would be tenable but uh as it
stands
what's happening
he's still thinking Duda okay he moves
his King I was saying maybe just block
with the black queen try and get the
Queens off the board at least because
you're facing a huge attack normally
that's good advice if you're getting
attacked try and trade the Queens but
beating himself up dude he's uh okay
then now he's smiling here he's
realizing he's on tilt he's trying to
get out of it but it's not easy as a
chess player when you're stuck in your
own head and uh you're being hit by a
tornado like this ah not easy it's
fascinating to watch him all the
emotions he's going through
do you think he
he knows he's losing this game he's just
not holding it off he's not even looking
at the board and another fantastic move
from Shaq I thought that yay he's gonna
move the queen Shaq is like no I'm gonna
give up my queen but in Return of course
he's threatening to capture the queen I
mean such a classy move it's like the
Incredible Hulk the catchphrators
catchphrases smash Hulk smash Shack
Attack that's his phrase and every move
is just an attack he's creating threats
on every turn
I mean this is so classy yeah the White
Queen just simply cannot be captured
right now I have a feeling dude is going
to resign uh but
what else can you do you just have to
applaud the opponent that's why dude is
smiling because he knows
he hasn't actually played that badly
dude it's just Shacks on fire and uh
sometimes you have to applaud you have
to take your hats off to the opponent
Shaq knows he's winning as well he looks
so calm looking away drinking some tea
or water
and let's just show this final tactic in
this position most humans the queen is
attacked you drop back the queen you
give a check but uh not Shaq he wants to
counter he drops his Knight back and uh
he's hitting the black queen key
Defender if Black's Rook takes the White
Queen now not only do you win the black
queen but you end up with a fork and you
win a rook for free and uh the reason
this is so strong as well is the black
queen has nowhere good to go she's tied
down defending her Knight for example if
she drops back to this Square defending
her Knight then uh this check is going
to be deadly
from the front and when the king drops
back everything wins here but for
example you can just take a pawn jump in
with the Knight next move and Checkmate
is coming
we'll see this and he just looks away
after making the move Duda
he seems finished with this game yeah
absolutely I mean his position is in
tatters there's nothing he can do to
salvage this and uh you see it there
so much emotions for young Christoph
Duda right now
yeah
what a game again uh it's so hard to
pick out highlights how are we going to
sum up this game it's like bang bang
every move's so surprising so Direct
so creative just brilliant yeah I mean
Shaq Has Come Today
like a man inspired guys there are not
enough superlatives right now to
describe Shaq's play he's in his element
I wish I was capable of playing chess
like this I mean uh yeah I mean it's a
it's kind of easy and just to think
about strategy you learn principles you
hear these phrases all the time but how
do you teach this it's just uh it's just
a mindset it's just being brave on every
move
going for the opponent's throat never
ever backing down it's not even just the
chest itself which is beautiful it's uh
yeah that mentality I have to say it's
very beginner friendly as well even I
can sort of see the power in his
attacking moves and and the joy and the
sacrifices and the craziness yeah
exactly and that's why I always
recommend to play starting up the game
work on those tactics Shack clearly when
he was younger was going through tactic
books he was working on calculation and
young players they should learn to
attack that's the hardest thing to teach
actually in chess you can teach end
games teach the defense teach openings
later in life but attacking and that's
something you need to hone when you're
young when you don't have that fear in
you yeah he's had that since a young age
yeah and Shaq has a very special story
actually because uh when he grew up he
grew up in a very small apartment and
there wasn't that much room in this
apartment for him to go and study and
there we see porn takes porn on the
board and so every day he would uh get
up at five in the morning and before
going to school he would go to the park
and just study and read books wow and
there we see the Rook attack the queen
and the queen give a check and once
again the black king it's caught in the
crossfire there's some Rooks that are
going to calm down and give checks
yeah there's a lot of open lines in the
middle of the board towards that black
king and white is playing without his
Rooks as you mentioned your banker and
uh the ingredients for any successful
attack use every piece
yeah white Brooks I mean he's basically
won the game without his Rook so far um
but to put the icing on the cake you
need to use those pieces
I'm not sure which Rook could you use
First
it looks a bit scary that the black
light squid Bishop is on the same
diagonal as the white king that's the
one uh kind of hope for Duda but
everything's protected white tonight
actually protects his King
and uh yeah the Rooks I mean you can
bring them in either order I think you
want to put them on the two Central
files the E and D files and
Plex defenses will collapse yeah plus
nine the computer says
yeah it's uh
definitely move around trap the king the
one thing that I would say is that don't
check the black king into safety I mean
what you want to do the black king is in
the middle of the board keep it there
keep it caged
um I mean we saw a game I think in the
game between um
Duda and uh Carlson where black uh
Carlson's King was in the middle of the
board but it got checked into safety and
then of course the job became a lot more
difficult but it's very very natural to
give checks yeah be aware it's very
tempting and that's the first thing we
taught to calculate after all so the
most natural move here would be one of
the Rooks to give a check he does start
this way but Black's King needs three
maybe even four moves to run into the
into the left corner where it might be
safe so you still have a couple of moves
to catch it in the middle and not let it
run any further
and uh yeah I'm expecting the other
white Rook to come into the game
okay first he pushes a pawn defensive
chess
cool customer not what we're used to
from Shaq but the logic behind that one
is that Black's light Squad Bishop was
on the same diagonal as White's King but
now White's King is super safe so now it
you can play go back to that one track
mind of attacking you've shored up your
own defenses and now I'm just putting
that last piece into the game actually
until this last Pawn was captured I was
doing a count White had a rook and four
pawns for two pieces so if you do some
maths a rook and four pawns that was
worth nine same as a queen uh black had
two pieces worth six so white was
actually upper materials despite all of
Shaq sacrifices earlier
and uh dude are still shaking his head
black doesn't have any threats you can
just improve for its uh pieces yeah
it's also tempting to give checks for
the knights because unfortunately the
king is two squares away from going into
safety
and yeah it's going to be in trouble on
the sea line yeah that's true in order
to get to safety it has to cross onto
dangerous funds first and Duda it's
heartbroken yeah yeah I mean but you
have to feel for dude and there you go
the rug comes and cages the king king is
going to be kept in the middle of the
board and now white has a deadly threat
of coming forward with a knight to give
a check on E6 yeah the night check is
gonna be the killer I just want to say
as well this is like a pincer movement
it's like one Rook cuts the king from
running to the right the other Rook is
going to cut the king from running to
the left and therefore it's stuck in the
middle and it won't have any Escape
squares for example if it continues its
journey to try and hide in the corner
then it steps onto a open file and now
at the very least working just step the
pawn forward and win this bishop that's
pinned it can't move and uh yeah there's
pincer movement with the two Roxas
so classy and deadly as well
um yeah nothing to do against this track
the king is caught
game over I think we'll see Duda resign
uh in the next two or three moves
yeah and let's try to defend it but not
quite enough
he looks uh like he is ready to resign
young Kristoff do that and I can't
believe the drama on this final day of
aim chess rapid
o is about to uh go two points up and in
game three doodle will have to win that
game to uh have a chance to decide Us in
the rapid portion if it is a draw a win
for Mom derov we will head straight to
Blitz tie breaks to decide the winner of
the aim chess rapid
wow yeah who would have predicted that
yeah I was saying it's going to be a
really tough day for Maduro if you'd
have to slowly work his way into it
nope he started with a bag and uh he
needs to go on that way okay the only
kind of thing you could trip over here
is the clock one minute for managerov he
does look slightly nervous
they do say winning a one game that's
the hardest thing in chess he's done all
the hard work
can he put on the finishing touches
that black king just looks completely
naked and just a void of any uh shelter
in the middle of the board White's Queen
could drop back give a check
I mean there must be plenty of ways here
yeah you kind of feel that the White
Queen is the one person that's missing
from the white attack everyone else is
doing their job so get her in yeah so
you could drop her back for example two
squares and give a check there but
um okay pushes upon what's the idea
behind this one uh surprising it did
occur to me but uh Pawn takes porn
aha oh he's so good and uh we have to
show the idea David sure so uh it looks
like this Pawn was doing nothing he's
throwing it forward and uh okay if the
bishop takes then now the king is
properly cut off No Escape along these
files the White Queen is now able to
come into the center of the board and
look at this the White Queen the white
Rooks they are going to trap this King
this is going to end in Checkmate but
you mentioned a plan here you make a
pawn takes porn yeah now you want to
destabilize the bishop because it's
defending a key Defender and uh be Pawn
forward and ask that question has to
move and once it goes well the queen can
deliver a devastating check yeah and uh
for example Bishop takes porn and now we
see why uh lured this Pawn onto the B6
Square because now it's easy food for
the White Queen Queen takes and yeah
this is I mean he's seeing three moves
four moves tactics even with one minute
on his clock and uh okay you called it
there Ivanka this is on the board
and okay dude is going for the white
king now he's brought his Rook down to
sacrifice he's trying to open up whites
King it's not going to work it's going
to be too late the White Knight can
simply jump back and defend but there is
some threat here there is a threat of
Checkmate along this diagonal if the
Knight is captured but it's not gonna
work because the queen Retreats give the
check yeah and defends her Knight and
next move white can simply gobble up the
bishop
it's going to be game over White's gonna
be ahead two Rooks and uh there we go
dude does resign wow he goes up by two
points jaclyard mom jar look at him